i'm not sure i can show up on a
stranger's doorstep with this mustache
i'm gonna shave that's better good
morning hank it's wednesday it's the
third day of pizzamas let's go to brazil
indiana somebody in brazil indiana
ordered some pizzama stuff so i thought
i would partially fill their order and
also my book the anthropocene reviewed
comes out this week in brazil and so i
you know i can't go there right now
because of gestures broadly so i'm gonna
go to brazil indiana to celebrate brazil
indiana is a small town just over an
hour's drive away from my home in
indianapolis which i suppose is a long
way to go to deliver a pizza machine and
some stickers but
whatever it's not like i have a packed
social calendar here comes brazil okay i
have made it to brazil indiana but it
turns out this person does not actually
live in like downtown brazil they live
15 minutes away so i am now going to
drive to their house and then come back
to brazil now this is proper indiana
it's just
it's just corn okay i'm on a dirt road
and i'm not like uh brimming with
confidence that google maps has nailed
this one
i hope this person's home oh yep
somebody's coming out okay hold on um
i'm an author and a youtuber that
i think she watches well those people
were lovely and they have beautiful
ducks in guinea fowl unfortunately the
person who actually ordered the pizza
miss stuff wasn't there she's at work
and i feel like
i should meet her like it's weird to go
to their house and drop the pizza stuff
off and not meet the actual person so
i'm just gonna go
to their work and hopefully be able to
say hello this is turning into like a
little bit of a day of errands which in
some ways is my favorite kind of day
like one time when i was in high school
i saw the novelist kurt vonnegut give a
lecture by the way i am back in downtown
brazil indiana this is a replica of a
famous brazilian fountain that was given
to the city of brazil indiana by the
nation of brazil almost 70 years ago and
i just want everyone to know that it is
lovely and well cared for but right so i
heard kurt vonnegut speak once and
mostly what i remember is that he kept
smoking cigarettes inside the auditorium
and the people at the university were
like you can't smoke and he was like
yeah what are you gonna do you already
paid me but i also remember he did this
bit about how most of adult life is just
what he called farting around like you
go to the post office and then you take
this thing to that person and then you
pay some bills and so on and at the time
i remember thinking no life is joy and
love and loss and yearning and pain and
hunger
and i still think that life is those
things but
it's also farting around but now i have
a clear and unambiguous mission to my
day which is to say hello to this one
person who ordered pizza miss stuff and
if the good lord is willing and the
creek don't rise i am gonna do it okay
just four and a half hours into my
journey having visited brazil twice but
it turned out i didn't actually need to
go to brazil i have reached my
destination and now i am hopefully going
to meet this person who bought some
pizza miss merch i have met betsy hi
so i decided to come to your work
oh thank you also my wife is like
they make the best bread in indiana so
you have to buy some yeah we do make
really good right i'm back home i did
not have the day i thought i was gonna
have instead i had a much better day
betsy and her family are lovely and it
was so nice to be reminded that people
can be so warm and generous and the
fountain in brazil reminded me that such
kindness and generosity can extend
across vast expanses of time and
distance so yeah it was just a day of
farting around the thing that high
school me feared most about adulthood
but
i loved it i find myself thinking about
a different vonnegut line i urge you he
once wrote to please notice when you are
happy and exclaim or murmur or think at
some point if this isn't nice i don't
know what is what a nice day i had happy
pizza mess hank i'll see you on friday
no
tomorrow